[MUSIC]
Conflict is costly for the economy.
People when they think about conflict,
they often think about the emotive parts
of conflict like the visceral images that
we get on television and things like that.
And often the economic side that
we all benefit when there's peace.
And we all lose when there's conflict
is often kind of thrown by the wayside.
But we thought, well, maybe if we
expose people to the opportunity of
trading stocks, this might make them more
aware of the kind of the gains to society.
And might change their voting behavior and
their attitudes towards
the peace process as well.
And that's exactly what we found.
What we found was that being supposed
to maybe $50 to $100 worth of stock.
Even that exposure for
a period of four to seven weeks was
enough to change people's attitudes.
To help them become more
financially literate, and
to change their voting decisions
in a fairly substantial way.
People were really
changing their votes and
their attitudes towards the peace process
based on the gains to Israel's economy.
So it's really a kind
of sociotropic thing.
I think that people will begin
to appreciate that there's this
common good that's the Israeli economy.
Stock markets potentially
are an imperfect but
nonetheless a nonpartisan
gauge of that economy.
And by being exposed to the stock market,
they get this nonpartisan metric for
measuring and
evaluating different policies.
[MUSIC]
Finance I think is particularly promising
in many ways because it's really about
sharing the future..
This idea of using financial
instruments to really have our people
share in the gains from society as
well as incentivize them to work for
the common good, is really a powerful
idea that isn't just restricted to firms.
It's also something that we
could do collectively as well.
If we are all invested in the market
portfolio or index funds,
we all benefit when the economy benefits.
This focus on the common good, this
incentive to support the common good, and
this nonpartisan metric about what
the common good is can really, we think,
be a very prudent way to mitigate
polarization and conflict.
[MUSIC]